hello everyone this next game I'm about
to show you is actually a very famous
the a smooth miniature game by Tigran
Petrosian it was played in 1971 in vice
and the netherlands and he's playing
against a very strong Dutch Grand Master
Hunter a I'm sorry won the Dutch
championship four times and even won the
Open Canadian championship in 1971
together with Boris Spassky so it's it's
a very rare to see an 8th move miniature
game played by players of these this
caliber so let's see this intriguing
game
Petrosyan is white in these place c4 we
have nice that we have a 5 Knight to c3
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
g3 Bishop to b4 the Trojan plays Knight
to d5 we have a nice capture some d5
seek after some defiled and here
red pushes g4 so Petrosyan captures seek
after study captures on c6 we have it
captures on f3 and Petrosyan plays Queen
to b3 and this is move 8 and in this
position contrary resigned the game now
look at the position I'm not going to
tell you why hunter resigned the game I
would like you to tell me why he
resigned in the comments below and yeah
like I said this is a very famous game
some of you might have seen it already
but those of you who haven't I'm sure
I'm sure you'll enjoy it and as usual
you can check two of my previous
previous videos here in the upper left
video you can still join my giveaway too
you can win a the official feed a
digital chess plug the dgt 2010 so to
check it out if you haven't had the
opportunity and yeah that's it hope you
enjoyed it and I will see you soon